well this past year has taken a toll on
all of our health both
physically and mentally everyone has
battled during isolation especially kids
20 ccsd students have taken their own
lives since march
of 2020 during this pandemic it has been
so tragic to talk about
one group of students is now trying to
prevent another peer from taking their
own life
bianca holmen is live right now with
more on what they're doing good morning
bianca this is so important
hey good morning alex this is such an
important topic like you said
one life taken is one too many and so
there are students here at legacy high
school
that are reaching out and taking a stand
against this and they want to let other
teens know that
you can text or call someone if you need
help take a listen
this this learning is tough but you
aren't alone behind the mask
j4g students are working hard to balance
their mental health and wellness too
i am resilient we are thankful
i am determined behind the match jfungi
students are dedicated to
healthy mental wellness school is not
just about learning
it's about supporting each other through
the journey of learning
yeah so there's a group of students from
jasper nevada's graduate
program that's here at legacy and they
with the guidance of their teacher these
students created
that video at a valley park and so this
was part of a national competition
called love
project lifting our voices for equity
and teens here
were challenged to identify an issue in
their community and work to make a
positive impact and our las vegas
students recognized that more education
was needed around mental health and so
many students say
they are or they have friends who are
struggling with anxiety depression
and it's really stemmed from the
pandemic so being isolated
has really taken a toll on a lot of
students because there are some home
life stressors
my hope is that everybody
would not be like this and be more like
this
because we're all like this and
especially
during kobe right now i hope they take
away that
nobody's really alone in this situation
everybody has
hopefully somebody they can talk to and
if not they can
try to reach out to somebody you know
maybe somebody will listen
yeah and so there are resources if you
as a teen are listening to this or you
know your teen is struggling
there's numbers listed on the ccsd
website so here's one on your screen
right now prevention hotline
1-800-273-talk
and there's also a text hotline we know
our teens like to text so they can text
listen to 839863 if they are having some
troubling thoughts and of course
there is that first line of defense
friends family or even a trusted teacher
or high school guidance counselor
reporting live from legacy high school
bianca holman
8 news now